And the quick answer is output, in that we are allowed to
have arbitrary input values, but the outputs tend to be binary.
For example, slow and fast.
Now this kind of output is called discrete, but
in many learning problems, your output could be continues as well.
So for example, if the input is the height of a person, and you put it output is
the weight, then what you find is probably a function like this.
It says that the taller a person, the more a person weights.
And in this case the output is not a binary concept like, light or heavy.
It's a continuous concept, and the output itself is also continuous.
So this is what we call continuous supervised learning